Speaker 1: Let's start today with mass
shootings. You know, whenever there is news
of a specific mass shooting, understandably,
the focus becomes the facts of that particular
situation. When we had the Buffalo mass shooting
where this 18 year old was targeting black people,
this was in Buffalo, New York, not this past
weekend, but the previous one. We immediately,
understandably correctly spoke about the details
of that incident. Where did the individual come
from? What were the motivations of the individual?
Who were the victims? What was the response? What
has been the political response? And on and
on. And whenever we do that, we often will lose
the perspective that there are so many of these
mass shootings in the United States that it would
almost be a full daily podcast just to keep up
with the mass shootings that are taking place in
the United States. Now, I spoke to a couple of
people yesterday, just casually texted friends
and said, hey, I'm researching for a story I'm
doing. If I just asked how many mass shootings
have there been in 2022 so far without looking
anything up? What's your sense? And many of them
wrote back something like, well, I'm aware of like
three or four specific ones that like made the
news to the to the threshold that I was aware of
it. So there's probably been like 40 or 50 because
we have a huge mass shooting problem here in
the United States. We have had, as of yesterday,
210 mass shootings in the United States so far.
It's only May. It's only May and we have had 210
mass shootings, never mind individual shootings
as well as shootings in which two but not more
than two people were injured or killed. Remember,
if one person shoots two people. By most metrics,
that's not considered a mass shooting. You could
argue that it should be, but depending on the
archive or state statistics you look at, it only
is considered a mass shooting when three or four
people are injured or killed. And bearing
that in mind, if you go to the gun violence
archive and you can download a spreadsheet
of this, you will see 210 actually. In fact,
I believe the number is now 211 since I
last looked at this. There's there was a
mass shooting yesterday in South Carolina, North
Charleston, where five people were injured. So it
is now 211 mass shootings in the United States.
Every single one of these is a story that impacts
many people, families, friends, coworkers,
etc.. If we pick a random one of these,
just for example, the second most recent one,
which when I looked yesterday was the most
recent one. When you look at that one that was in
Goshen, Indiana, by the way, a place I've been to
and it took place on Rosemary Court. When you
look at the victims, there was a 17 year old male
who was killed. There was a female injured,
another female injured, another female injured.
And the suspect is believed to be a 20 year
old male who was also killed. According to
the information that we have here. And for every
single one of these, typically there is a media
source that you can look at. In this case, the
media source takes us looks like it's a Facebook
page, a release from the Goshen Police Department
talking about how an emergency call was received,
that a shooting took place at a residence. Five
individuals were injured, according to the report.
EMT is when were sent out to injured females were
airlifted to a trauma hospital in Fort Wayne.
One was taken to a hospital in South Bend. An
injured male was taken to Goshen Hospital but has
been declared deceased and one male was pronounced
deceased at the scene. Every single one of these
is a story that affects so many people's lives,
and most of these don't even make national news.
And one of the things I've talked about before,
NPR, also, about nine days ago, did a story on
this. At that point, nine days ago, there had been
198 mass shootings. Now we're already up to 211.
Whenever there is a news story that doesn't have a
clear beginning, middle and end, it often will not
make it into the news or whenever there's an
event that like that. So when we talk about,
well, there was a shooting where one person
was killed and it gets more attention
then thousands of people in the United States
or however many are going hungry, whereas that's
a major story. How do we still have hunger in
a country as rich as the United States? Well,
it comes to what makes a good story for corporate
media. And I've spoken about this before
a terrorist attacks, weather events, individual
shootings, votes on a particular bill.
Those have a defined typically beginning, middle
and end. They have very clear players. There
are very clear sort of goalposts for what is the
coverage expected to be and how are these topics
discussed? Regular corporate media is not really
set up to talk about hunger in the United States
in an ongoing way. Okay. There is a food stamp
bill. Democrats for Republicans it guess whatever.
But the news corporate for profit news
is not really set up to talk about that.
Malaria in Africa, dysentery, in a way. But these
are not the types of stories that corporate media
is designed to address. And even when you look
at the politics, the political stories, the
intractable and corrosive nature of how we select
our representatives and then how they don't really
represent our interests, that's an ongoing and
major story. Arguably, it's one of the fundamental
stories about how American politics is broken.
It doesn't really have a clear beginning, middle
and end. And as a result, it's why you often don't
see much about it in corporate news. So to go back
to the beginning, 210 to 111 now mass shootings in
the United States, and it is not even Memorial Day